[Musique]
ce mardi 7 juillet le département de la
réunion recevait une délégation chinoise
du centre de recherche pour la
diplomatie non gouvernementales de
l'association du peuple chinois pour
l'initier à l'étranger ne rencontrent
pour célébrer 55 ans de relations
diplomatiques entre nos deux pays
l'occasion pour l'instant d'inaugurer
les dons de 420 livres faits à la
bibliothèque départementale
l'amitié entre la réunion et la chine
existe depuis longtemps
vous savez les réunionnais shoot
origines de chine où leurs ancêtres qui
ont traversé le dossier indien pour
arriver à la réunion dans la communauté
chinoise
vous avez la fédération des associations
chinoises qui ont toujours entretenu et
la relance
la relation entre la réunion et la chine
et cette année dans le quatre ans de
l'établissement de leurs relations
diplomatiques entre la chine et la
france nous sommes venus à la réunion
pour approfondir et développer cette
relation qui nous tient à coeur
dans le cadre de cette belle ouverture
exemplaire d'une bibliothèque d'amitié
avec votre association
c'est la volonté a été proposé une
réciprocité
le département de la réunion fera tout
de livres pour justement en réciprocité
plus près de la réunion plus près de la
france à partir de l'eau saumâtre
l'objectif est de renforcer les liens
entre la france et la chine de nouveaux
projets verront le jour très
prochainement les partenariats entre la
shinari
ils sont portés par les institutions
mais aussi par les associations par les
artistes en ce qui concerne la
collectivité départementale
nous allons par exemple l'année
prochaine en 2020 clear un artiste
chinois un artiste qui a déjà une
renommée sur le plan international et
qui va venir à la fois travailler avec
d'autres artistes de la réunion et
exposer son travail dans un
établissement de du département pour
terminer cette matinée la réunion a
remis à la fina panier rempli de nos
produits locaux
[Musique]